foreign
it was an average day for me and my mom
I was 11 years old and we were at Costco
I was probably scoping out some free
samples when she got the call from a 212
number
it was a nice admissions lady from the
prestigious fence School in all girls
private school on the upper east side of
Manhattan
we have a spot off the waitlist for your
daughter to join our incoming 6th grade
class
thank you very much but we cannot afford
that it was my mom's response
we have a substantial financial aid
package for your daughter
these 10 words changed my life forever
I grew up in the South Bronx in a
neighborhood where over 90 percent of
the residents are either black and or
Latino
and about 25 percent of families live in
poverty double the national average
studies conducted by a non-profit
organization called opportunity insights
at Harvard University have found that
rates of upward mobile Mobility vary
substantially based on the neighborhood
in which you grew up
to put it plainly
people like me from places like the
Bronx are far less likely to achieve
intergenerational upward Mobility
but every year that a child spends in a
high Mobility environment increases
their earnings in adulthood
so although I didn't know it at the time
gaining access to this fence school was
like being hand plucked from my
neighborhood from my community
and placed on a brand new trajectory
one that would Propel me to new heights
but would require some sacrifices along
the way
the journey from there actually sounds
pretty linear
at Spence the expectation amongst my
classmates was no longer to just go to
college it was to of course go to the
ivy league
one eventually I started at the
University of Pennsylvania I
internalized this expectation that I
couldn't get any regular job
I had to make the big bucks in
consulting or Finance or technology
when eventually I started my career at
Google my family was beyond proud
I came out here to the bay and I made
more money than any of them ever had
so naturally they thought it was a
little off when I decided to quit join
the startup and go back to school
which brings me here
to the GSP
where we literally talk about changing
the world
not bad for Dominican and Puerto Rican
girl from the boogie down Bronx am I
right
[Music]
[Applause]
so then why do I sometimes feel so
shitty
the truth is somewhere along this
journey I internalized this notion that
upward Mobility was the goal no matter
what Against All Odds and to be honest
it has been hard
I've had experiences that have
challenged my sense of self my sense of
home my sense of belonging
and those challenges cannot simply be
offset by any number of gains in
Prestige or status or wealth
to give you an example of the first one
challenges to my sense of self let's
take it back to Spence
on my first day of orientation it didn't
take me long to figure out that I was a
little different
I was the only non-white Latina in my
class of about 60 girls
only a handful of us commuted from
outside of Manhattan
and Upon returning home from orientation
I naively asked Mom
what's the Hamptons
I went from being just one of many black
and brown kids at my public elementary
school to being the only
and at such a young age being the only
felt inherently wrong
there was a right way to do this whole
private school thing and it was not to
look or to act like me
naturally I did what I could to blend in
I chemically permanently straightened my
beautiful curls so that I could tone it
down
and I toned down my Bronx accent also
known as code switching
I mean because y'all imagine if I pulled
up to that fancy-ass school on some of
y'all y'all are dead ass bugging bro
like
absolutely not that wasn't gonna work
it felt like every single day I was
checking parts of my identity at the
door the most fundamental parts of who I
am
and I know what some of you are thinking
middle school is challenging for
everyone it's really awkward and to that
I say I agree
in addition to this existential crisis
that I experienced related to my status
and my race I also had braces and
glasses in middle school so I get it
while yes school can be a time for
self-discovery for all for so many
underrepresented minorities at Elite
predominantly white institutions yes
like the GSP
we are implicitly and explicitly told
that our fundamental way of being our
sense of self Behavior appearance is
wrong
inadequate or inferior
and that set challenge to our sense of
self can take years to recover
now for my next Point how many of you
grew up in the Bay Area
okay most of you did not great because
I'm talking to you anyway
it seems like a lot of you somewhere
along your journey had to leave home
like me
it seemed like the more I achieved in
life the further away from home I really
had to go
not just physically but metaphorically
as I continue to gain access to such
Elite institutions that were so
different from my neighborhood back home
I honestly started to feel disconnected
from what home was
some of you might relate to this feeling
whether you came here from Lebanon
from Peru
from Nigeria
how does it feel to return home to a
place that you once knew so well
and suddenly feel like an outsider
how do we stay grounded and connected to
our communities
to our home
now this sense of home this challenge to
my sense of home is ever evolving
and for now I try to bring small pieces
of home with me in whatever space I
enter
which brings me here to the GSP once
again
I stand before you as a second year
student at fanford GSB one of the best
and most exclusive Business Schools in
the world
I've been navigating predominantly white
institutions as a young woman of color
for almost two decades and now I can
hang
I mean I've got the Google logo the
startup and the VC experience
and I could speak the lingo without
skipping a Beat
private Equity this golfing skiing nuts
just kidding y'all I really still don't
know how to golf or how to ski but
that's all right we're making it happen
all right
against the laws I made it I can finally
say that I belong at places like the GSP
and yet
yes even here at places like the gsv
there have been experiences that have
challenged that sense of belonging
take last quarter for example
I was at a school-sponsored retreat and
one of my facilitators walked right by
me at breakfast while I was grabbing an
extra yogurt at the buffet
not once but twice
which was odd because she was usually
very warm and welcoming and we knew each
other very well
finally she turned to me and said hi can
I get a spoon
now this was not the first time that I
was mistaken as kitchen staff in my life
but still I was shocked I was frozen
when she realized the mistake that she
made she said I'm so sorry Amanda I
thought you were in uniform
I looked down at my clothes and I was
wearing the same comfy clothes that
everyone else in my class was wearing
what was the implication of this
incident
of this microaggression
you look more like a member of the
kitchen staff
than like a student at the GSB
and you know what
it's actually true
a McKinsey report on the economic state
of Latinos in the United States in 2022
found that Latinos are indeed over
represented in low-wage jobs and
underrepresented in Corporate America
in fact just one percent of Fortune 500
board seats are held by Latina women
one percent
the least of any ethnic or demographic
group in the United States
we talk a lot about imposter syndrome
here at the gsv I'm sure everyone in
this room has felt it at one point in
another
but what if that imposter syndrome was
validated
all the time
by innocent yet frequent
microaggressions
by statistics
or by simply looking around and
recognizing that success
does not quite look like you
now we all know inequalities exist we
talk about systemic inequity the
importance of Dei but for me
and for so many people like me
we live it
every single day
and we seldom talk about these
challenges that we experience while
we're moving up the ladder
so to my allies in the room
my ask of you is not unlike things that
I've heard that you've probably heard
many times before
go to the training be curious be
inclusive
and that's great I love y'all I really
do but to be honest this talk is not for
you
for my fellow others in the room
we've come such a long way
I know how exhausting it can be to feel
like the only
to be the other
to deal with these challenges to your
sense of self your sense of home your
sense of belonging
but man this distance that we've
traveled
it's taught us about what's even
possible
it's given us the sense of grit and
resilience that is truly unmatched
and it gives us a deep sense of purpose
and this purpose is what I choose to
lean into
when I leave the GSP I'll work for teams
and organizations where I can step into
my power as the other the only
and continue to bring others up
as I climb
if my grandparents can come from their
small Caribbean islands to achieve their
version of economic Mobility than this
I got this
I will continue to rise up so long as I
stay grounded and who I am and where I
come from
and I hope you can too thank you
[Applause]
[Music]